i can't tell if these are dreams or
thoughts if they're thoughts then we
know all this actually happened but if
their dreams then all this banta writing
is just patting the runtime of the tv
show playing in boba's head these bones
here are actually from the band that we
saw killed a couple episodes ago how do
they decompose so quickly well it's
actually because we've been watching fat
stomped through the desert for over a
thousand years
unwanted sexual advances despite being
thrown straight to the back of the
throat mr snuffleupagus manages to
somehow chew this barbecue also this
show made me use the phrase straight to
the back of the throat in reference to
mr snuffleupagus and it's going to take
a while for me to unpack that cutting
from this campfire scene directly to
boba finding a mortally wounded finnick
makes it seem like this whole sequence
takes place in one night so if you
haven't seen the mandalorian episode
where this all plays out then you don't
know that an entire day has passed and
that finnic has been lying here dying
for a very long time which justifies
boba taking her to mr roboto for
emergency healthcare as opposed to a
licensed physician and since this is all
that took place during the mandalorian
i'm setting everything up into this
point as a previously on which makes
this a record 5 minutes and 38 seconds
of previously awning if i wasn't so
bored i might be impressed choosing
google glass over terminator eyes show
us temporarily derailed by this creepy
exploration of the cyborg gaze
the music that's playing isn't mad about
me and does not contain any figuring or
modal nodes come on disney give the
people what they want someone's
definitely wanting us to compare this
mod parlor to a tattoo parlor but never
explains the implication of a lower back
modification or the function of an upper
back modification aren't you a little
old to be here while aegis i'm more
concerned with the absurdity of this
statement old people are getting modded
all the time we all know at least one
old person that's been pimped out with
metallic joints a partially mechanized
heart and transition lenses this woman
is about to die
well you should have started with that
show wants us to think that services
would not have been rendered had this
undisclosed amount of money not been
dropped on the bench but fett literally
led with she needs modification instead
of saying something like holy [ __ ] her
insides are on the outside please
someone help this robotication mods on
for so much of the some time that i
began to question my own dependence on
technology and now i wonder if i'm
already a cyborg what are the rules does
the tech need to be inside me what if
i'm inside it does driving my car make
me a cyborg i need to know hey you got
some borg in my star wars
cover all that beautiful machinery it
might be considerably less beautiful to
the person who's expecting an actual
abdomen above their legs as opposed to a
new branch of cyberdyne industries take
the black melon we'll help you recover
or help her rust finnick just had most
of her innards replaced with pistons and
this warboy's offering aquacola instead
of guzzling boba's dead throwing shade
at bubble tea help me recover my fire
spray gunship seems safe to assume that
the creators don't want to use the name
of boba's ship here and i get and
respect this decision but that doesn't
excuse trying to flex on fennec by name
dropping the make and model of this
thing like the last time my ship got
towed i didn't call my friend larry and
say i need a ride to bail out my toyota
prius if the ship is yours
why don't you just ask for it back of
course i might not like the answer this
response does not preclude the
possibility of asking first then if you
don't like the answer you can proceed
with your planned boba branded bloodbath
with no instructions the surveillance
drone knows immediately where to go in
which building it needs to take
measurements of well i love all the
droids in this franchise especially that
incorrigible bb-8 overly convenient tech
is really doing most of the heavy
lifting in the whole star wars days of
the futuristic past aesthetic
i feel like the spy ball would have had
a much better time hiding if it didn't
insist on chirping away to itself and
wasn't covered in red lights that served
no purpose other than to be something
interesting for us to look at find other
benthas make baby benthus boba doesn't
even consider that a bantha might want
to focus on their career i'm tired of
working for idiots who are going to get
me killed my reaction to reading another
questionable script from the new tv sins
writer somehow makes it into the episode
people like us
i'll get to decide when we're finished
badass loner statement based on no
empirical evidence whatsoever cliche i'm
going to take a guess there on a huge
amount of these convenient greats so why
wouldn't one of these few hundred guards
be oh i don't know guarding it sure one
guard will make a difference against
these two but better than leaving it
totally exposed making these cuts closer
to the rock would have prevented these
jacket barons from making their entrance
so gosh darn unsafe remember put this
scene together thought it was funny to
have the rat catcher singe it's poor
little robo taint running through a fire
pit in a desperate attempt to escape a
murderous boba fett the sin here is
failure to mind the gap
[Music]
this show man and veer so hard from
dune-like space hopper into wallace and
gromidesque shenanigans in the space of
minutes and that would be kind of cool
if i thought for even a second it was
remotely intentional pew pews pew pews
pew pews
excitement what is this droid why does
it explode so readily and if someone
knew that this thing would blow up from
one shot why wouldn't you program it to
avoid crossfire instead of walking
directly into it what the hell are you
doing you need to get the gate open but
i can't see a thing it's almost as if
the designer of the ship was going for
something cool and marketable instead of
anything resembling a practical flying
machine hmm disney i've gotta close the
ramp finnick goes on to do a sick flip
throw thing to this baddie and then hops
inside with just enough time to make
this shot and scowl at the camera as the
door closes all of which was very cool
but in no way required the ramp to be
closed immediately all this did was open
up the possibility of having to
awkwardly ask boba to reopen the ramp if
she missed this shot of boba fett taking
revenge on this speeder bike gang is all
the cool and maybe one of the best uses
of a dutch angle i've ever seen but also
multiple murders putting your fire spray
gunship this close to the desert
sphincter damn it
i can't see a thing being surprised you
can't see a thing when you're the one
who just blocked all the light fire in
the hall this works slash they survived
this because there is no forcing way
that finnick knew the exploding mcguffin
would choose to propel itself out of
this opening once the hatch was opened
and fall off the ship and continue to
fall into the sarlacc maw and then be
eaten by the munchie sphincter this is a
[ __ ] convenience on top of a
contrivance wrapped in a blanket of
unbelievable good fortune how many times
have you been hired to do a job that was
avoidable
if they only took the time to think then
you and i would be out of work hey us
too congratulations master pet
you are completely healed what about the
scars on the inside with all due respect
to the drama boba's experienced we were
all thinking what about the scars on his
face sure it'd been kind of cruel of
finnick to say that but she's a former
assassin and he's a former bounty hunter
these are cruel people or at least have
claimed the experience on their resumes
the discount gorn seriously tried this
knowing full well it had nothing to
follow up with other than a look of fear
and the knowledge that he can probably
get replacement limbs at the local mod
shop you were a legend
in the name chrysanton drew crowds by
the thousands wow this exposition about
ted's past really drew me in apparently
it really drew boba fett in to the
building because other than acquiring
this information the show hasn't given
any reason for him to be here right now
hit it max
we've had a veritable plethora of exotic
names like flip finnick garfiela quacks
ted and lorth appeal but one of these
two is just called [ __ ] max jabba the
hutt once sat upon that throne and then
bib fortuna took his place as someone
who regularly watches shows out of order
i refuse to be tamed i get that this
backstory delivered through exposition
can be helpful for people not familiar
with the broader franchise but that
doesn't make it okay it just means i'm
complicit so we both get a sin also this
show's really testing my ability to
suspend disbelief on anyone seriously
using the name bib for tuna putting your
hat on the dinner table what prevents us
all from killing you and taking what we
want
whoever said raincourse didn't have a
sense of dramatic timing was well
actually they were spot on because
there's no way he knew to growl at this
exact moment for maximum intimidation
are you fat for smuggling looking like
you had that [ __ ] rehearsed i see you
they all appear to have parked 100 yards
away i don't know if boba told them to
or they've all got step counters and are
trying to get that 10k in but this seems
foolish when you consider the size of
this garage i mean at least pull up to
the door credits can buy muscle
if you know where to look finnick is
essentially saying that you can buy
something if you know where to go buy it
never have truer words been
spoken to us if anyone
here you knew
well i'm not gonna let my meatball get
away from me this time
we are bored
please client do not cut my hair what's
the best i could do under the
circumstances sucks to be you nerd
what the hell are you doing
i have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
500
i can offer you something no client ever
has
what's that
forced
laughing
good tea nice house
what's wrong dude you yell up
nobody
calls me yellow
all right
i don't know about you
but i take comfort in that